a digital currency issued by your
government is going to be very dangerous
number one it's programmable which means
it can be programmed to only be spent on
specific items for example you go to
fill up your car but your money is
declined because you've reached your
pollution allowance by buying too much
meat this week number two it can expire
which forces you to spend diminishing
your ability to build long-lasting
wealth and save essentially becoming a
slave to the system because you're gonna
have to work until the day you die
number three it's centralized which
means it's entirely in the control of
your government so the same rubbish
monetary policy which is causing
astronomical inflation will continue to
occur we saw what happened in canada
when people had a different opinion
about forced injections to that of the
government and they had their bank
accounts frozen so with cbdc's if you
hold the wrong opinion this freezing of
your assets will be much more efficient
ultimately the level of control that
will come from a central bank digital
currency will be nothing like we've ever
seen before